[Music]
on this thursday night a shelter holding
hundreds of ukrainians bombed out by
russian forces the frantic search for
survivors and the ukrainian president
stern words for germany's government
preparing for the russian president's
next move his soviet past is catching up
with him putin's chilling new message an
american basketball star's detention in
russia extended it's very dangerous for
any american to be held in russia the
growing chorus of calls to free brittany
griner and a heartwarming welcome to
ukrainians we are getting google
translate onto all of our devices the
canadians opening up their hearts and
homes
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight tracy tom
good evening and thank you for joining
us western officials say russia's ground
advance in ukraine has slowed as the
invasion enters its fourth week but its
deadly and destructive assaults from the
air have ramped up several cities have
endured furious shelling of civilian
sites
this is the aftermath of bombing in the
eastern city of kharkiv
days of relentless rockets have left
much of it in ruins but so far russian
soldiers have failed to capture the city
in southeastern ukraine rescuers
continue to search for survivors after a
russian airstrike hit a theater in the
besieged port city of mariupol
hundreds of women and children have been
taking shelter there
local officials say up to 90 percent of
the city has been destroyed
russian forces have captured a swath of
territory along ukraine's black sea
coast stretching towards the country's
third largest city odessa where soldiers
and civilians alike are preparing for
battle
our jeff semple is on the ground near
odessa and joins us from there tonight
jeff tracy the city of odessa here on
ukraine's southern coast is known as the
pearl of the black sea the historic port
city with a pre-war population of around
1 million people is also widely believed
to be one of vladimir putin's next
targets
since the first day of russia's invasion
of ukraine the fires of war have burned
hottest in the south
in mariopol a city under siege hundreds
huddled together inside this theater
basement satellite images show they'd
painted the word children in large
letters next to the building so bombers
would see it but on wednesday a russian
air strike hit
rescue crews are now pulling survivors
from the rubble from mariupol russia's
war path has pushed west past crimea
through kursan to mikolaiv
where ukrainian soldiers are dying
faster than they can be buried the city
of five hundred thousand is so far
holding the line but if it falls
russia's next target will be one of the
most important we're here in the city of
odessa the southern coast of ukraine
which among other things is famous for
its stunning beaches but these days
they're serving a much different purpose
as you can see dozens of volunteers for
days now have been working here
all day filling bags with sand it's our
home and we need to defend it software
engineer dimitro kurick has spent the
past three weeks filling sandbags from
the coastline a russian fleet is barely
visible ominously hovering on the
horizon possibly waiting for the land
forces to arrive from the east before
making their move
carrick lives here with his wife and
four-year-old and isn't sure how much
longer they can stay together but he's
also never felt prouder to be ukrainian
right now we are
a united nation some of those sandbags
are brought here to odessa's historic
city center its renowned architecture
and sweeping streetscapes are now a war
zone in waiting
it's painful to see this soldier says
normally these streets would be crowded
with artists and people partying
enjoying life but now we're ready to
defend the city at any cost i went to
the military like one and a half years
ago but i would have never expected
something like that to happen and stand
in the center for this so we're armed
with a gun never what about you will
will you leave no i'll stand here to
leave our end well some stand guard
others dig deep
alexander sadovnikov lives next to a
bunker that leads to a labyrinth beneath
the city one of the world's largest
networks of urban tunnels 60 meters deep
and around 2500 kilometers long
these catacombs were dug as stone mines
200 years ago and provided shelter
during the second world war sadovnikov
is now equipping the tunnels with
lighting and wireless internet some
families have brought supplies
this shelter is four floors underground
he says it should withstand any bombing
and save people's lives
if odessa falls russia will claim this
coastline making ukraine a landlocked
country and dealing a huge blow both
militarily and economically most of
ukraine's trade comes through the sea
and most of that flows through the city
of odessa
tracy
jeff semple near odessa ukraine thank
you
major cities across ukraine are enduring
russia's wrath as ukrainian forces keep
their enemy on the ground at bay but as
crystal gomencing reports the civilian
toll of this conflict is only growing
missiles fires and fear for three weeks
this has been the reality for those
living in war zones across ukraine
once again russian artillery fire
continues to strike on the edges of the
ukrainian capital
western intelligence indicates the
russian invasion in many areas has
stalled and key cities including key for
the 35-hour curfew lifted thursday
remain in ukrainian control
control however doesn't mean safety the
enemy makes no success and they cannot
get those cities and for that reason
they start terrorist actions
they start just chaotically imprecisely
shelling those cities from their
artillery and their missiles it seems
what russia can't capture
it destroys
unconfirmed reports say at least 21 were
killed in this strike east of keefe
in nearby harkeef where there's little
left to reduce to ruins
smoke continues to fill the sky the
beribashova market
once considered one of the largest in
europe is in flames after a missile
strike the fire spread to nearby homes
i don't even know what to say the fire
is here and there you have to drive
around and see
ukrainian president vladimir zelensky
again visited a hospital his staff
released these images the visit followed
yet another direct and impassioned
address to western politicians
this time he's imploring germany's
leader to take more action
you are again behind the wall not the
berlin one but in the middle of europe
between freedom and captivity and it is
growing with every bomb on our land
the bombardments are ongoing and deadly
the u.n has confirmed that more than 700
civilians have died so far and more than
1100 have been injured and the real yet
to be verified numbers
are likely to be much higher
tracy
crystal commansing reporting in london
thank you crystal
canada is imposing new sanctions on 22
bella russian officials for supporting
the war in ukraine global affairs canada
says they are members of belarus's
defense department and allowed their
country to serve as a launch pad for the
russian invasion
in a statement foreign affairs minister
melanie jolie says canada implores
alexander lukashenka to end his support
for the russian invasion we will not
hesitate to take further action the
world is watching
the mayor of the occupied city of
melatopal has been freed six days after
russian forces took him captive and
installed a kremlin-friendly mayor in
his place
in a post to his social media channels
ivan federov thanked ukrainian president
vladimir zelensky for not abandoning him
ukrainian officials say federov was
freed during a special operation
though there are reports he was released
in exchange for nine russian prisoners
of war
u.s president joe biden will meet with
his chinese counterpart xi jinping
tomorrow to discuss the escalating war
in ukraine china is facing a critical
choice back russia or help broker a deal
to end the bloody conflict
russian president vladimir putin is not
backing down instead he's turning to
intimidation and chilling words aimed at
keeping russians on his side heather
yorick's west reports
they were ominous words from the russian
president any nation is able to
distinguish true patriots from scum and
traitors i am convinced a necessary
purge of society will only strengthen
our country this is very scary language
he says you know russia has to cleanse
itself you see so many echoes of
the soviet union now and what what he's
doing words of fear and intimidation
evoking some of the darkest chapters of
modern history as vladimir putin
intensifies information's oppression at
home and aggression abroad
leaving his western rivals to grapple
with what could be next yesterday
president biden said that in his opinion
war crimes have been committed in
ukraine
personally
i agree there remains concerns that
russia may further escalate its brutal
assault by using chemical weapons in
ukraine so nato members are continuing
to hold the line they will deliver
weapons and humanitarian support but
their fighters will stay on the
sidelines nato has a responsibility to
prevent this conflict from escalating
further there's no such thing as a
no-fly zone light light
a no-fly zone means that you're in in a
in a conflict with russia there's also
the question of china on friday joe
biden will speak with xi jinping a
collision of two superpowers and
strategic world views this call also
comes that we have made clear our deep
concerns about china's alignment with
russia and the potential implications
and consequences of that if china
chooses to support russia the u.s warns
swift economic sanctions will follow but
the country could also choose to become
a peacemaker using its economic leverage
and xi jinping's long-time relationship
with the russian president to bring
about a ceasefire heather eric's west
global news washington
to help people fleeing the war in
ukraine canada has launched a new
temporary residence program applications
are now being accepted for an unlimited
number of ukrainians to come for up to
three years not two as previously
suggested
eligibility is also being extended to
family members regardless of their
nationality
elementary and high school students can
register for school as soon as they
arrive and all application fees are
being waived for more details you can
visit our website globalnews.ca
the un's refugee agency says more than
3.1 million people have fled ukraine and
according to the canada border services
agency more than 3 300 ukrainian
nationals arrived in canada between
february 21st and march 13th including
permanent residents
and those refugees need places to stay
coming up the generous canadians coming
to the rescue plus the travelers who
will still need a covet test before
entering canada
health canada is preparing to lift the
pre-arrival testing requirement for
fully vaccinated travelers entering this
country even though covet-19 cases are
rising again in other parts of the globe
the world health organization says new
infections are up eight percent jamie
maraca reports on when the change takes
place and if it's the right time to
relax the rule
it won't be happening in time for the
return of thousands of march breakers
but come april 1st fully vaccinated
travelers won't have to worry about
testing before returning home fully
vaccinated travelers may still may still
continue to undergo random testing upon
entry to canada but they are no longer
required to quarantine while awaiting
their results passengers who are only
partially vaccinated or have not had a
shot will still have to provide a
molecular test and they'll have to stay
home for two weeks while awaiting
results
[Laughter]
[Applause]
and it's a completely different set of
rules if you're setting sail cruise ship
passengers will have to test to get on
the ship and everyone on board has to be
fully vast unvaccinated travelers with
antibodies from natural infection have
been left out that immunity for most
diseases is better than the vaccination
but for the coronavirus it seems not
necessarily
so it may have to do with the
amount of
virus virus particles we took in when we
infected our vaccine rates are generally
quite high over 80 percent nationally
but only 56 percent of eligible
canadians have their booster timothy sly
suggests three doses of the coveted
vaccine should now be considered a full
course there is no change to the
definition of a fully
vaccinated canadian as cova cases
continue to rise in other countries
health experts will be relying on random
traveler testing and surveillance
i think we made a grievous error in
early days of omicron by banning the
very countries that had gone to great
lengths to give the red alert to the
entire world should that alarm bell be
sounded again which is likely officials
say we will adjust restrictions with the
intention of avoiding our past pandemic
mistakes jamie morocco global news
toronto
health canada has approved the use of
moderna's covet 19 vaccine for children
aged 6 to 11. the pediatric regimen
consists of two half doses taken one
month apart
health canada says clinical trials
indicate the vaccine is equally
effective for children in this age group
as it is for young adults
from courtside to moscow's clutches
ahead is this american athlete now
russia's political prisoner
[Music]
two university students from ontario are
the only survivors of a head-on crash in
texas that left nine others dead
authorities say a pickup truck crossed
into oncoming traffic tuesday night and
crashed head-on into a van carrying
members of a university golf team
nineteen-year-old dayton price and
twenty-year-old hayden underhill were
taken to hospital by helicopter with
critical injuries
i'm thankful that hayden survived but at
the same time we're thinking about the
families and friends of everyone else
who aren't as lucky as us here to be
able to see our friend again
u.s transportation officials say a
13-year-old was behind the wheel of the
pickup and that one of the truck's front
tires blew out before the collision
there is growing concern for an american
basketball star detained in russia
brittany griner has been held since
february on allegations of drug
smuggling today russian media reported
she'll remain behind bars until at least
may now details surrounding her case are
limited and as mike drole reports some
worry she's caught in a political battle
between moscow and washington
brittany griner strode into a moscow
court on thursday her latest step on an
odyssey through the russian judicial
system with no clear end in sight state
media reported the american basketball
star will be detained at least another
two months furthering fear she's become
a political prisoner well i'm terrified
i think we all should be very concerned
about brittany griner's safety and all
the hostages who are being held in
russia it's unclear exactly when the 31
year old was arrested but it was first
reported last month as tensions between
the kremlin and the west escalated in
the run-up to russia's invasion of
ukraine
this video was released of griner at the
moscow airport having her bag searched
by federal agents who say they found
vape cartridges containing hash oil an
offense that in russia could carry a
10-year prison sentence
she's not stupid you just don't know
what to believe there's so many
different things you don't know what's
true what's false
but i just can't believe she would
knowingly
carry
illegal drugs
in a carry-on bag
at an airport griner is no stranger to
russia and its laws having played in the
country the past seven years during the
wnba off season the u.s state department
has had a do not travel advisory for
russia since 2020. what we haven't seen
yet is any explicit indication that the
case is being politicized the danger
that's lurking here of course is uh that
some kind of hostage diplomacy situation
might take place uh given the the very
poor state of relations between the u.s
and russia right now fear of stoking
russian anger could be why those closest
to the case have said little most
notably griner's wife who has pleaded
for privacy as they work to get her home
mike relay global news toronto
next canadians stepping up to welcome
ukrainian refugees into their homes
[Music]
for many ukrainians fleeing the war the
road ahead is dark and very uncertain
canada is stepping up with government
support and canadians are opening their
hearts and homes as jamie dahl reports
many are going all out to welcome those
in desperate need of some calm right now
she is a fifth generation ukrainian
canadian and for heather foisey those
roots run deep this was actually near my
bomb shelter where i stayed over
watching the news feeds it's just
heartbreaking watching what these people
are going through and while she doesn't
have any family in the country today
she's cried more tears for the people
there than she's willing to admit it's
been an emotional rollercoaster of ups
and downs between anxiety depression
this feeling of hopelessness and she
decided to do something about it she
reached out on facebook and connected
with a mother who fled ukraine with her
young son and now foisy and her family
are preparing to welcome them into their
home we've already set our son phoenix
down and let him know that we're going
to be hosting a family and he's excited
to be able to help
we are getting google translate onto all
of our devices deeply stirred sabrina
stetzko has had her home prepared for a
ukrainian family for weeks now she's
also created a podcast and a network on
facebook hoping to connect new arrivals
with resources and community many are
arriving traumatized with they lost
everything in in addition loved ones and
even pets
so you know there's a lot going on and
so this would be a way for everyone
locally to just come together airbnb
says so far 24 000 people around the
world including 750 canadians have
offered their properties free of charge
or at very discounted rates to
ukrainians seeking somewhere to live
canada is home to many ukrainians and
many people of ukrainian descent and i
think what we're seeing is that sense of
kindness and that sense of community
stretch from coast to coast to coast
it's just a simple act of kindness
people helping people in unimaginable
crisis according to heather foisie
providing a safe space for a mother and
her son
has also given her a sense of purpose
during a conflict unfolding a world away
i know that it's only one action but
many people that are doing this is going
to be able to help
help many families jb doll global news
calgary
and that is global national for this
thursday night i'm tracy tong despite
this dark time it is heartwarming to see
canadians all over the country chipping
in to support ukrainians we'll leave you
tonight with some of those efforts
my original goal was around 50
but then
i started raising a lot more than i
expected
that is 11 year old haley townsend of
abbotsford bc
she's making and selling bracelets and
crafts raising money to help ukrainians
and as you heard she was aiming for
about fifty dollars she's now raised
over a thousand and she's not alone in
toronto margot rocket is crafting these
beautiful paper flowers in support of
ukraine she has given away hundreds for
free but she's asking people to donate
to the red cross in return thank you for
watching good night
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you